you're familiar with semen retention
obviously
explain it too so you know just the
whole process of
holding on to your yeah your essence you
know did you do that a lot before your
fights
yes
not because i thought it helped me
because other great fighters did and i
wanted to be able to be like them if
they can do it and that made them great
i had to do that too how do you feel
like it affected your life it didn't
affect me
it's not the this is what i found out
from the old trainers the old trainers
didn't mind if you got some [ __ ] but
they didn't want you chasing [ __ ] they
didn't want you all night [ __ ]
chasing [ __ ] now you gotta come running
in the morning you're hanging out all
night you get an hour to sleep to go run
that's what the you can get some [ __ ]
don't abuse it
is worse than getting it's like this
like it's like the root of the root of
all evil is not it's it's not money it's
the greed the greed oh yes you know what
i'm saying
that's what the not getting the chasing
is what gets your ass kicked that's the
fact
this [ __ ] getting this dick boy
i don't know why people say that made
you weak that's not a lie that's a some
old remedy cell yeah if a guy can
control you from [ __ ] he could make
you do anything
but i will say this mike even to me as a
fighter
oh no man i'll be getting sleepy son i
get sleepy you know i mean especially if
it's an aggressive drawing you know i
mean no you don't look at it like that
it's got that number let's see how i'm
gonna rip this [ __ ]
i'm an eagle maniac when it comes to
that yeah
i look at it like i look at it like oh
you don't look at the right way you
don't live the right way
this got to be god you look at this like
it's gone
it is and that's why i be holding on
they getting hit but like i just i just
don't release all the time i'm just
talking [ __ ] my wife would kick my
[ __ ]
[ __ ] talking [ __ ] for the raiders
this [ __ ] [ __ ]
but keep that in though
okay i'm talking [ __ ] about the rating
[ __ ] steve retention
damn the no fat community gonna come
after you right no fat no fat you ever
heard of that community tell me about
that just like semen retention no
fabulous like this whole new thing
youtube no fat like don't fap don't beat
you me
why didn't they say that was self that
was safe sex before remember
remember lady the surgeon general you
remember that jerk it off then she said
the black lady be hardest get the lady
that's saying right now
masturbation
masturbation healthy surgeon general
said masturbate
to prevent aids and yeah come on
masturbation i was in the 90s and [ __ ]
cuz i know i'm not lying [ __ ]
there's a new time though like with this
new generation is is a lot of like you
know girls in general black lady who's
pushing the you know anti-porn [ __ ]
because they saying the porn [ __ ]
[ __ ] mind it's almost like chasing
you
[ __ ]
listen peep game know what it's like
it's like you're a rap it's like you on
the um the treadmill and you're in your
mind you keep running you're running
you're running and you never get the
[ __ ] whatever you want
about this or why did this come to mind
for you what with like the
retention system oh because like you
know with boxing like i've i've heard it
a lot like seeming retention related to
fighters you know what i mean like like
i've heard that throughout time like
fighting they hold on to their it sense
to make you stronger it holds on your
testosterone i feel like it does make
you angry mike it makes you mean as a
[ __ ] yeah
doesn't make you better no no
yeah that's her name and she's still
alive she ain't like g.o.d or
maybe type in her name next to
masturbation yeah that would be awesome
i remember i was young she was saying
masturbation
masturbate masturbate bastard
[ __ ] man i don't believe in spilling
your own messes i mean you know i ain't
judging nobody but you know just to each
his own me i rather hold on to my [ __ ]
damn what you talking about to get this
chick for encouraging masturbation
a black woman said that [ __ ] nothing
[ __ ]
these statements
administration but that schools should
encourage kids to jerk off it was the
final straw
before
that aids elders was asked if she
thought teaching children about
masturbation might reduce safe unsafe
sex yes she replied i think that it's
something that is a part of human
sexuality and it's part of something
that perhaps should be taught but we've
not even taught our children the very
basics
damn that's what she said
what do y'all think about that and i
ain't no [ __ ] you only get jerk off
so long
you know yeah every day i gotta jerk off
and come on and it's okay one day that's
two days but not every [ __ ] day i
gotta jerk off
i mean you're definitely tired after all
of that
ah oh man so tell us more man what you
got planned man do you have any children
man yeah i got i got one
um three years old what's the name she's
girl in the go rain so that's my baby
girl three going on 13. that's a
beautiful brother beautiful my little
she's a three-nature is what i call it
[ __ ] but yeah um not trying to have any
more anytime soon you never know only
god could decide that's a fact that is a
fact i mean god definitely decided for
me yeah i have a next presidency you
don't want no kids [ __ ] that's why i'll
be trying to hold on mike i'm trying to
tell you
listen
you can only do that for a certain
amount of time so you have to get as
much out as you can i mean [ __ ] to eat
his own you know
i plan on living for a long time that's
awesome you dig
[Music]